so you mentioned all your time in
Oklahoma City changing cities as well
moving you know coming to Houston big
city with the Texans and the Astros and
so many other stars what would have been
your thoughts about the city of Houston
thus far and just the opportunity being
in the city presents for you it's hot as
hell
[Laughter]
bother than that now it's been been
great getting getting acclimated and
figuring out a way to get the family
settled in and I'm looking forward to it
obviously it's a different change but
growing up in LA and kind of said we
been a big city and living there in the
summertime but planning one is
definitely different and it's gonna be
something I look forward to and you know
it's exciting for free agents out there
it's 75 degrees all summer's a lot so
Russell people in Houston have seen you
for years in the back again common
opponent but what can you say that those
of us have only seen you as an opponent
don't know about you something that
you'd like for people to know that I'm a
nice guy I think that's the biggest
thing obviously when I play the game and
I play basketball there's no I'm going
out to compete going out to be able to
to win and I don't care how that looks
and you know I'm always gonna stay that
way but I think off the floor for me as
a that's a huge thing figuring out and
understanding that I am human I'm a
human being I am a good person just so
you guys know and I do care about the
community the team my teammates
everybody I mean I just want to do
whatever I can do to make sure that we
have a chance to win